the origin of money
um
it's pretty simple to explain actually
you know we've been operating as nomadic
hunter-gatherers for a very long time on
this planet and
Commerce that is exchange of of goods
and services it's probably relatively
new
uh the Advent of Agriculture roughly Ten
Thousand Eleven thousand years ago
depending on who you ask but let's say
it's you know 10 000 years ago
um
played a big part in the creation of uh
money so what money is all that money
really is at the end of the day I don't
even have my wallet here to bust out a
bill but you know what a 20 Bill looks
like all that all that that paper money
is
is a store of value
I want you to understand something the
only reason why
twenty dollars has twenty dollars worth
of buying power today and I'm talking
about the US Dollars you know so the
Greenback
the only reason why it has twenty
dollars worth of buying power today is
because people universally agree that it
has twenty dollars worth of buying power
today you give a twenty dollar bill to
an alien to a crow to any other animal
on the planet it's absolutely useless
and they wouldn't even know how to wipe
their ass with it it has no meaning to
them it has no bearing it's only humans
that it has some sort of exchange of
value to it now
the reason why money was created was to
store value so let me paint a picture
for you let's go back in a time machine
10 11 12 000 years ago
and people were operating
and shifting into their little tribes
right
and there was a guy
that was maybe good with goats there
might have been another guy that was
getting in a blacksmithing there might
have been another guy that just started
into Agriculture and he was farming
wheat or something like that and some of
those items are perishable if you're a
blacksmith and you're making horseshoes
for horses horseshoes are pretty durable
you know you can you can buy a horseshoe
and leave it on a shelf and it's good
for a long period of time doesn't
degrade it might rust over time if it's
exposed to certain elements but at the
end of the day it's it's it's very
durable
other things that are perishable let's
say wheat you harvest wheat it's it's
perishable after a certain period of
time if it's not stored properly if it's
not made in a bread or other goods for
example
um and that that value diminishes rather
quickly
so they had a problem
animals die too obviously you know they
can get sick
um you know so they had a problem you
know there's there's certain things that
people wanted from others that were
perishable there are certain things that
were durable so they need to figure out
a way to store that value in something
because maybe when the guy
needed horseshoes that was growing the
wheat didn't have wheat to trade because
it wasn't ready to be harvested for
another three or four weeks or something
like that he didn't have any means or
ability to go and buy horseshoes for his
plow horses let's say
just making up the story but just sort
of give you an example
so they had to figure out a way to store
value in something
throughout history they've stored value
in
seashells
gold obviously you know precious metals
gold and silver copper you know stuff
like that they've stored value in tulips
even at one point I thought that was you
know a good story value and then all of
that you know pivoted and shifted over
time into things like you know paper
money and credit and you know now we
have digital currency like Bitcoin and
stuff like that today so
the
the long story is rather long and I'm
not going to get into you know bore you
but that's essentially what money is
it's just a store of value so whenever
you come across somebody that's got a
lot of money
they didn't steal it from people
generally speaking you know for the most
part if they've acquired a lot of wealth
then they've stored a lot of value in
money which means they've provided a lot
of value to other people right the
reason why Elon Musk is the richest guy
in the world is because he's assumed the
NASA contracts that the space shuttle
used to do and he's throwing satellites
into orbit like it's going out of style
uh he's got the I think the heaviest
lift rocket that's ever been built you
know in history uh he makes electric
cars solar panels like dudes up to some
good right so you know he's created some
value in the world for people and he
stored that value in money that's all
that money is and money's got a lot of
messed up properties if we're being
honest you know because the way the
government can print unlimited
quantities of it
um and I'm not gonna gonna propose that
I'm smart enough to break down all of
these things in simple terms for you
guys I'd suggest watching um YouTubers
like George Gammon like to have him on
every every few months uh on my main
Channel just sort of chop it up and
catch up what's going on with the
economy but that's essentially you know
the long and short of it that's that is
what the history of money is
um Jack
that's an interesting Super Chat how
many times have you failed before a
million dollars
I don't know all of my life until I got
the million dollars I would say
um
early 30s something like that
um you're gonna fail a lot more times
than you win you know when it comes to
making money and creating wealth but
we'll save the creating wealth one for
another episode of the unplugged Alpha
that'll that'll probably be uh
number two or number three so you can
keep an eye out for that one later on
anyway uh welcome to the new channel
members guys appreciate you joining and
supporting the channel and all that good
stuff
so the other parts of the show that I
wanted to spend some time on is around
credit because that's that's the main
way today that people are using money uh
the masses you know if you will and
again I started out in the credit
collection industry uh I left that in
two three I think it was 2003. it was
the start of 2003 I started my business
February 8 2003 is when I Incorporated
it I know that and I took a package and
I went home in November of 2002.
and I talked about that part in my book
The unplugged Alpha if you guys are new
to the channel get the book it's on
Amazon uh there's an audible version
that I narrated The book's also getting
updated too by the way there's going to
be a first edition update out later on
this year uh and there'll be a special
announcement with what's gonna follow
after that and then there's a second
book coming out towards the end of the
year that's going to fill in a lot of
the stuff that should have gone in the
first book I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out